JOE RODRIGUEZ: Hello,
and welcome everyone
to today's session on
Modernizing Texas' Best
Retail Chain with Anthos.
My name is Joe Rodriguez,
Platform Engineering Manager
for H-E-B, responsible for
hybrid cloud deployment.
JUSTIN TURNER: Hi.
I'm Justin Turner.
I'm the Senior
Engineering Manager
responsible for digital
fulfillment at H-E-B.
JOE RODRIGUEZ: Today
we'll talk a little bit
about who we are as a company.
And hopefully peel back the
onion and share with you
our road to platform
modernization with Anthos
and the effects that
it's having on helping
us ship digital assets to
H-E-B and to our customers.
To be clear, this is not an
exhaustive technical talk,
but rather a
behind-the-scenes look
at some of the thinking
and decision making
that went into building
out the platform
and our technical competency.
Therefore, I will cover
the work and rationale
that we put into building the
platform, and how we got here.
And my colleague Justin
will cover the details
of engineering applications
on the platform
for his digital
fulfillment team.
Who are we?
We are H-E-B. We
are Texas proud.
We believe that no store
does more for Texas
than H-E-B. We are the largest
retail grocer in Texas,
and have the distinct
pleasure of serving
over 9 million hungry Texans
daily within our store
footprint.
We hail from the great
city of San Antonio.
But in actuality,
our humble beginnings
started in Kerrville,
Texas in 1905.
H-E-B later moved its
headquarters in the 1940s
to Corpus Christi, Texas.
But, for the last
35 plus years, we
have called San Antonio home.
Here's an example of one
of our flagship stores
in the Houston area.
And although each store is
unique into their own right,
they are all set
up to do the same.
They are set up to efficiently
and effectively serve
our customers.
As you can imagine from
a little bit of math,
we are 115 years young.
In that 115 years, we've managed
to deploy 400 plus stores
within our fleet.
Now, those stores range from
central south, east, and now
West Texas.
Over 350 of them.
But now, we also have about 70
plus stores in Northern Mexico.
According to dunnhumby,
a data science
firm out of the UK
in 2019, they put out
a study to see who is
the best retail grocery
company for the US for 2020.
They're happy to say that
we were voted number one.
Regardless of any accolade,
you should know this--
as a company, H-E-B
is relentless.
We are relentlessly
dedicated to our customers.
Getting food into the
homes of hungry families
in a timely fashion, especially
during this crazy time
in history, is our
number one objective.
Even so, we do this while
trying to provide the best
service, price,
customer experience,
whether in our stores or online.
It's who we are.
Onto platform modernization.
Why modernize our platform?
Simply put, it's
about serving Texans.
It's what we do.
Getting food into the hands and
onto the tables of our Texans
is what this is about.
Although it sounds simple,
every day, this task
seems to get increasingly
more and more complex,
which is why we
know that if we're
going to be serving the Lone
Star State over the next 115
years, this journey to
platform modernization
and digital
transformation is and will
be the key to our
future and success.
Now before modernizing
anything, we
had to do a bit of
introspection and realignment.
In other words, we had
to get our head straight.
Did I mention that
we're 115 years old?
We should think that
we're a little bit wise.
Well luckily, we
were wise enough
to realize that, if we're going
to be solving today's food
problems with yesterday's
tools and technology,
this would prove out
to be a very tall task.
So what we did is we
restructured and aligned
our engineering, operations,
and development teams
for the future and for success.
The next thing we did was
do a little bit of planning.
We knew that this digital
transformation does not
happen overnight.
So we started to plan for
a minimum of a two to four
year runway.
And when it comes to
the platform itself,
we saw three phases.
We called it crawl,
walk, and run.
But I will cover the
first two phases.
And Justin will make
mention of where
we're headed in the future at
the end of the presentation.
One of the first
things we did was
looked at the state
of our DevOps, right,
and how we should cope.
H-E-B has this
concept of own brand,
where we take something
good, like ice cream,
and make it better.
DevOps practices and
tooling is no other.
It is critical to the
path of the future.
Tooling.
In regards to tooling, this
has to do with newer tools
like Docker and Kubernetes.
And when it comes to
delivering applications,
we really had to take a hard
look at our CI/CD narrative.
Just by doing this, we
established our early mission,
which is a bold
statement unto itself.
And that is to empower
developers and accelerate
H-E-B's transformation from
a grocery to a tech company.
But, like any good
thing, we quickly
found out that this has
some inverse effects.
Empowering developers and
acceleration of transformation
really has some inverse
effects when it comes
to delivering our applications.
Much of what my colleague,
Justin, will cover
is exactly that-- living in
this new world on this new stack
and its effects on
application development.
The next thing we did was
address the issue of change.
Change within the
enterprises is very hard.
Change is hard in general.
But for digital transformation,
it is even harder.
I would care to say
that no one really
knows just how hard
something is unless you
have to go through it yourself.
When it comes to
the enterprise, I
think that the critical
thing to remember
is that enterprises
are much like ships.
They are a little
bit slower to turn.
Which is distinctly different
from a startup approach, right?
Startups are like tugboats,
speedboats, or even smaller
vessels.
They turn on a dime.
It takes an incredible
amount of retrofit work
to make ships turn on a dime
like these smaller vessels.
From an operational perspective,
one thing we had to do
was a bit of re learning,
or thinking or learning
differently, much
of like you would
from going from an
object-oriented programming
language with something
like Java to a functional
programming language with
something like [INAUDIBLE]..
The next thing we
did was formulate
a team that could really help
us move the ball forward.
What we did was
we formulated what
we called a GCP Tiger Team.
This is a shout out to those key
individuals who really helped
early on to establish
the footprint
and get us off to the races.
What they did was really focus
on setting the groundwork,
right?
Building that gap between
operations and developers,
focusing on reshaping
our culture,
introducing those new tools.
But in addition to that, it's
really taking a hard look
at changing the computing
mindset of the organization.
Now you may ask, what
do you mean by that?
Well, this is what we call
our Wizard of Oz moment.
Well considering that when
we started this, it was 2017.
And while the rest of the world
was moving towards Troll Factor
App and Cloud
Native, we were still
living in the tightly coupled
world of servers, VMs,
and mainframes.
Think about it.
Servers, VMs, and mainframes.
Servers, VMs and
mainframes, oh my!
You get the picture, right?
What this was about was
rethinking our compute mindset,
decoupling applications from
physical servers or VMs,
and really taking a look at
not treating these resources
as pets, much like a cat.
And really treating
them more like cattle.
I don't know about you,
but in Texas, we're
way better herding
cattle than we are pets.
Which led us to our
container first approach.
We believe that
this is the fastest
method of reinventing
our platform
and delivering applications
at scale and into the future.
We did this by engaging
Google with GCP and GKE.
One thing that we
didn't want to do
is we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel.
So we focused on becoming
consumers and establishing
that muscle memory that it
takes to get good at delivering
applications.
What we focused on and what
we tried to get out of this
was three key things
for our platform.
That application decoupling
that we talked about,
a faster engineering lifecycle,
and a more systematic approach
to actually
delivering the tools,
or rather, putting the
continuous in continuous
integration and delivery.
For our application
deployment, we
sought to have more
uniformed observability
of our applications,
really focus
on that operational agility
that most high performing
institutions look
for these days,
and really taking a policy
driven approach or a security
as code approach
to applications.
So wrapping up phase
one, it took over
about a year and a
half and we managed
to rewrite and migrate 16 to
18 production mainframe apps
into GKE.
And so not to steal
from any of what
Justin is about to talk about.
But what we began to notice
was a speed and delivery,
that operational agility that we
were looking for, consistency,
and, overall,
developer happiness.
So now, we're feeling
kind of comfortable
and walking through with
our heads in the clouds.
So the question now
became, how do we
bring this closer to home?
How do we do this on-prem
for applications that need
to sit within our four walls?
Which led to a new
mission, right?
Was to accelerate our value
creation for our developers.
And in addition, shift the
unit economics of engineering.
Which, really, is just an
intelligent way of saying,
how do we tackle certain
applications to go out first?
Now, this is where the proper
realignment and introspection
that I talked about earlier
really, really came into play.
This meant that in
order to be successful,
operations,
developers, engineers
had to be on the same place.
Such that there was frictionless
development, world class
operations, and
automatic repeatability
within our systems.
Enter Anthos.
Why Anthos, though, you know?
There is a variety of
solutions out there
currently in this space.
But what we really
wanted to do was
stick really close
to open source.
Meaning, we really were
looking for a raw Kubernetes
experience, right?
Continuing to build on
that technical competency
that we've just got through GKE.
And again, leverage that
existing support structure
that Google provides
us, should we need it.
Again, what this
is about is, why
we chose Anthos as our platform
for application modernization
was we were able to leverage
existing knowledge that
exists within our
data centers, in
particular with VMware, right?
Anthos sits on top of VMware,
and we have a very large VMware
footprint, we were
able to make use
of our technical
competencies to accelerate
the delivery of this platform.
In addition to that, tighter
grained control of deployment
for compliance applications,
should we need that.
The proximity to data.
We cannot put all of our
data out into the cloud.
So having these workloads run
very closely within our data
centers puts that data in close
proximity to these new systems.
Again, leveraging
that existing support
and leveraging the experience
that we have with Google.
In addition to
that, what we plan
to do in the future is use this
as a burstable launch point
into other clouds, is
the one key feature
that we haven't made
use of Anthos as of yet.
So what this gave us were
the essential building
blocks that we need to move
forward into the future.
These building blocks were
composed of Kubernetes, service
mesh technology, and
serverless technology
that we quite haven't
made use of yet,
but we will here shortly.
With that, I'm happy to announce
that we have now officially
launched our hybrid cloud
solution at H-E-B. It took us
about nine months
to sit with Google
and get this thing right.
But in February of this year,
we kicked off the project.
Happy to say that now, in
July, we are now in full beta.
And we hope to go to
full production come
August, September time frame.
We'll be sporting a new
application deployment approach
with get offs and some of
the other tooling like Argo
and what have you.
In addition to that,
our initial workloads
will target only stateless,
non-compliant applications.
We wholeheartedly
believe that we
can get an adoption rate of
5% to 15% of the applications
that we need to re-engineer.
And we can double that in 2021.
With that, I'll now turn it
over to my colleague Justin
to talk about his journey
through modernizing
digital fulfillment
on our platform.
JUSTIN TURNER: Hey, everybody.
For the next part of
this presentation,
we're going to be going through
a practical walkthrough of how
we took the path that Joe
blazed with his teams,
and really utilized that
to modernize and transform
how we deliver work in
digital fulfillment.
Digital fulfillment are the
engineering teams and custom
built tools that power
our curbside home delivery
business.
These are made up of web
and mobile applications,
as well as delivery
logistic smart
routing services that allow
us to efficiently deliver
groceries to our customers.
They are the tools that allow
our make-ready departments
to on-demand prepare
the items that are
part of our customer's orders.
And they are the tools
that allow our partners
to shop, manage orders,
and hand those orders off
efficiently and correctly to our
customers and delivery drivers.
So some of the reasons
we wanted to modernize
digital fulfillment
were due to the fact
that each of these
systems grew up
as a bespoke model that's
serving an independent business
need.
And over time, as our
business grew and changed,
the domains began to
overlap more and more, which
led to duplicate functionality
in each application.
As our business grew, we
knew we wanted better tools
to address the scaling
that came with that growth.
And due to the nature
of these systems,
there's a tight
symphony of events
that need to occur to get
our customers their groceries
on time and correctly.
And any disruption can
prevent us from doing that.
Additionally, the nature of
the business that we serve
has changed as the
pandemic goes on.
These tools allow our customers
to get groceries safely.
And a disruption to that
is something we don't want.
So uptime is of a
mission critical concern.
And we wanted better
tooling to address it.
We also have frequently
changing needs
due to the nature
of this business.
Each change that's
requested by the business,
simple as it may be, may
require complex changes
across all of these applications
and the entire ecosystem.
So we knew we wanted to better
serve the need for change.
So we decided that we needed
a new digital fulfillment
services ecosystem.
We asked ourselves, as
an engineering group,
what we wanted to get out
of a modernization journey
and rebuilding these systems.
We knew we wanted to
deliver work faster,
recover from incidents sooner.
We wanted to be more
scalable and resilient
to the realities
and complexities
of operating a complex system.
We wanted to empower our
engineers to grow and learn
more parts of the stack than
they had ever participated
in before, and learn
a lot of the new cloud
native tools that are
available to them.
We also wanted single
sources of truth
for every domain within
digital fulfillment.
So we decided that a
microservices approach
met these needs.
That said, we knew that
the road to microservices
was fraught with risks that
we could create a distributed
monolith, or a situation worse
than what we already had.
So we came up with a
simple set of principles
to help us avoid these traps and
be successful in our journey.
We wanted our services
to be stateless.
We wanted to reduce code
complexity with everything
that we did.
We wanted to encapsulate
functionality within services
to reduce operational
complexity, as well
as the chattiness
between services.
And we wanted loose coupling
between these services
so that we could fail gracefully
and keep most of the business
up should a failure occur.
And we knew we wanted
one database per service
to enforce the
microservice's discipline,
and ensure that we didn't
create a situation that
was bad for ourselves.
So the next step
was to establish
our domain driven design.
And we did this by following
the event storming process.
This allowed us to define
the events, triggers,
responses that make up the
digital fulfillment ecosystem.
From there, we took the
groupings of these events
and formed our bounded contexts,
which informed our domains
and ultimately led
to the initial design
for our services.
With this domain
driven design, we now
have what we needed
to get started.
We knew we didn't want to
show up with everything
all at once, with a
big bang approach.
So we picked the overlap between
last mile delivery and curbside
pickup domains to deliver
our first set of services,
specifically, in efficiently
loading the delivery vans
as they arrive to a curbside.
I'm happy to say that we were
successful in this journey,
and August of last year, we
delivered our first Cloud
native services to production.
It was a painful journey, and
we had a lot of early learnings
that informed the rest of it.
We learned, you need to
validate your assumptions early
and often about your
domain driven design,
and how you've
designed your services.
And not be afraid to redraw
boundaries as you see fit.
But you only learn about it by
validating those assumptions.
We learned that we
needed to invest time
in becoming familiar with
Cloud native patterns.
We had a new tool
set available to us,
but initially, we only
brought what we already
knew into the Cloud.
So we had to invest there.
You also need to focus
on the discipline
around the principles
of your services.
As you get closer
to the finish line,
the temptation is there to
subvert your principles to meet
the deadlines or what have you.
And it might get
you there sooner.
But it creates a worse situation
for yourself down the road.
So discipline around
your principles
is a key and important.
And we also learned
by doing a little
and getting those battle scars,
making the mistakes early,
we learned a lot.
And it made the rest of
our journey much smoother
with that experience.
These changes
allowed us to start
addressing our culture
in digital fulfillment
and how we do work.
We moved from two week
sprints, where we'd package up
potentially shippable
product increments,
and the risk associated with
two weeks' worth of work.
And were able to move to
weekly combine iterations
where we were continuously
delivering value to production.
We reformed ourselves from
a giant monolithic team
into several smaller squads
that could own their domains
and services end to end.
And they did that by
becoming full cycle engineers
and participating in more of the
stack than they had previously.
We measured our
success in this change
by using the four key metrics.
That allowed us to
identify areas of friction
that prevented us from
becoming high performing teams.
To become full
cycle engineers, we
had to build competencies in
parts of the stack we had never
really operated in before.
We started with the database
and performing backups
and restores, as
well as focusing
on the efficiency of our queries
in a way we never had before.
We also started building
our own CI/CD pipelines
with Cloud Build and Spinnaker.
And this allowed us to do things
like introduce canary analysis
to our deployments.
We then built a competency
around Kubernetes
itself and GKE.
And that allowed us to operate
our services end to end
and fully own what
we've built. We then
learned a lot of
different tools in GCP
that became available to us,
one of which was BigQuery.
It allowed us to
build dead dashboards
on the fly for our business,
as well as understand our data
in a way we never had before.
One of the other
competencies that we built
was feature flagging,
specifically
utilizing a tool that we built
ourselves for toggling features
on and off in a way that
makes sense for H-E-B.
And we open sourced this tool.
With the help of Joe's
team, we worked with him
to introduce the role
of SRE to our teams.
We embedded these
partners on our squads.
And they focused their
efforts on helping
us define SLIs, SLOs, and
refining our alerts until they
were actionable and meaningful.
They also helped us to find
good error budget policies.
And our stakeholders
agreed to them,
which allow us to change
our behavior should
we exceed our error budget.
We also refined our
incident response process,
so that we could put
our engineers on call
for what they build and
on healthy rotation,
so they can really demonstrate
that full end-to-end ownership.
The next thing that we
did was build a practice
around chaos engineering.
We did this by
bringing in Gremlin,
who through the use
of guided game days,
helped us build a mindset
around introducing failure
scientifically to what we build.
This allows us to validate
all of our assumptions
in our designs and
really understand
how our system is going to
perform when failures do occur.
This has grown into red
versus blue exercises, where
we can practice
incident response,
and is now growing even further
into us automating our chaos
engineering.
So we're at the point where a
new services are in production.
They're rolling out to stores.
And by the end of August,
our full digital fulfillment
ecosystem should be live
in every curbside location
at H-E-B.
Some of the key learnings
at this stage of the journey
have been that change
safety is vital.
As you start to move faster,
it increases the risk
that you can push an
error to production.
And so you need a lot of
automation around your testing,
so you can move at that
speed, as well as things
like canary analysis in
your deployment pipeline
to prevent you from pushing
things to production
that cause issues.
You need to size your
services for your teams.
And what I mean by that is,
as you remove complexity
from your code bases,
you're introducing it
into the operation
of your services.
And not every team needs
thousands of microservices.
So make sure that how
you size your services
is something that you
can successfully operate.
We also learned that
the distributed systems
are really hard.
A lot of our issues
here at the end
have been around fine tuning
our domain driven design
and redrawing those
boundary lines.
And you can't be afraid to fail.
But this is where that
validation of your assumptions
becomes key, as you
need to refine as you go
and not have to redesign
your system at the end
and build the muscle
around distributed systems.
Ultimately, this doesn't end.
This is your new normal.
We're doing this so we can
better serve our business.
But understanding that
there isn't a finish line
to all of this is a
key learning for us.
One of the most important
things we learned
is that focusing
on the people is
key to a successful
digital transformation.
And that's because the
people that do the work
are the ones that bear
the burden of learning
all of these new technologies,
changing how they deliver work.
The technical part of
this is the easiest part.
Providing a space for your
people to fail safely,
to learn, and investing in them
is how you navigate this change
successfully.
So we're at the next stage.
At the end of August,
Joe and I will
be working on our strategy to
take what we've built on GKE
and transition it
to GKE on-prem.
And then move that to
the edge in our stores,
so that we have that ultimate
level of reliability.
Our services can run right
next to our customers,
and weather the storm when
there's unexpected events
like a fiber cut.
Thank you for
attending our talk.
If you have any questions,
feel free to reach out
to Joe or myself.
We appreciate you.